[Musique]
c'est dans une ambiance conviviale que
s'est déroulé ce vendredi 25 mars dans
les jardins de la villa du département
la cérémonie organisée par la
collectivité en l'honneur des
producteurs réunionnais ayant décroché
des médailles au concours général
agricole lors du dernier salon de
l'agriculture
ici c'est l'excellence même qui
récompensait donc bravo à toutes les
personnes qui se sont vu reconnaître
leurs compétences à travers ses
médailles de bronze des médailles
d'argent des médailles d'or mais je
dirais aussi bravo à toutes les autres
personnes qui même si elles n'ont pas
été récompensés ont démontré la qualité
de leur savoir faire bravo à zot bravo à
la réunion qu'il gagne c'est comme cela
que nous allons avancer et vous pouvez
compter sur l'engagement du conseil
départemental pour continuer à vous
accompagner la feinte andréenne prime
aphatie le porte drapeau des lauréats en
obtenant deux médailles d'or grâce à ses
confitures de bananes aux fruits de la
passion et de papaye à la vanille
beaucoup d'émotion et surtout la
reconnaissance du travail et si on a des
doutes on les fixe est parce qu on sait
qu on fait de bons produits et je sais
que mes produits été bien appréciée à la
réunion mais là aussi au niveau national
donc ça veut ça m'encourage aussi
avancer dans ce
chemin vers ce chemin là l'autre
réunionnais en or s'appelle bernard
savreux toujours dans la confiture cette
fois-ci de litchi aux fruits de la
passion il a également décroché une
médaille d'argent et une médaille de
bronze pour d'autres compositions voir
c'est comment dire c'est une
satisfaction pour l'équipe
tout ce qu'on a quand même des salariés
donc c'est un ami une récompense de leur
travail aussi
après pour moi c'est plus à une échelle
locale en l'air ça aide énormément ça
aide énormément
comment dire les la communication qui
est fait autour est quand même très très
très intéressante il y a
et aussi la satisfaction des clients des
anciens clients surtout qu'ils ont
acheté et qui regrettent pas leur choix
de leur fournisseur est
effectivement aussi les nouveaux clients
une édition 2022 très réussi qui
préfigure celle de 2023 encore meilleur
pour le premier vice président serge
hoareau on avait tous envie de retrouver
le parc des expositions de versailles et
cette année blanche que nous avons
connue et c'était un succès l'édition
2022 restera dans les annales du salon
international de la du tout sûrs pour la
réunion vingt-deux exposants très
satisfait une
un partenariat avec l'ensemble des
institutions locales qui a très bien
fonctionné le département tant que chef
de file et et le résultat est là et bien
sûr quand on voit nos médaillés quand on
voit nos exposants dans leur façon de
s'exprimer
on a tous envie de dire à quand le
prochain 'le prochain c'est en 2023 et
bien évidemment nous serons au rendez
vous la réunion a également brillé dans
les catégories va ni alcool et miel
[Musique]